You gotta see this. This was a great one. This was sent to me by somebody.
I don't know, but this is the most up Instagram post.
Oh no, no, it's up. It's the grand poster the week.
Okay, good. This one's great. I don't, I, you know,
sometimes I don't do this most up Instagram posts of the week because it got
kind of like, I did a lot of them and I was like, okay, where does it go?
And whatever. And I know people love this segment and they keep hitting me.
I'll get to [inaudible]. It will send me, pops up most up his grandpa's a week.
But this one dude, I was like, I got to do it. Okay.
So this is of a picture of a girl posing, hardcore, uh, at dinner,
she's got one of those stupid drinks that anyone would drink because softball
it's got like a drink with like a peel in it, you know, just have a drink.
Don't put in it that I can't drink. So this girl is doing it.
She's in a red dress. It's so photo-shopped the photo,
you know, a lot of makeup on this girl, but also photo-shopped okay.
And she's doing it like this. She's doing it like this.
If you're on a video podcast, she's doing it like this,
like almost touching her hair kind of, but not touching her hair.
Cause it's sexy when you're kind of almost doing something,
but not actually doing it. Right?
Like if you look at somebody from far away and you're like,
is your mouth open or closed? You just get a bone doggy because of it.
Anyway, uh, here it, this,
this is the actual caption
I can tell how unintelligent a man is by how stupid he thinks I am.
First of all.
Hat.
First of all,
the fact that you made this about men already is just amazingly genius.
You don't know it, but you accidental genius. Okay.
And also within the first line,
the only thing that we know is you're insecure. Okay?
That's it.
She writes the person you are looking at, first of all,
talking about it. Like it's not her, but it is her. Hey,
are you Ricky Henderson? Then don't refer to yourself in the third.
As the person you're looking at,
Uh,
the person you were looking at has attended the best educational institutions in
the world. Been top of the class,
all of her life smashed seven years of law school
and training to become a lawyer.
No lawyer has said I smashed law school unless also you're a guy.
And you do date rape, um,
sailed through three wall street firms to date.
Sailed is exceptionally intelligent,
intuitive and has worked very hard for everything. She's right.
Lee rightfully deservingly earned herself without relying on anyone
else. All right.
And we'll continue to accomplish greatness for many more years to come. I mean,
you don't know that who knows
could die. You know, if you happen to be mistaken,
expect this, this drives me nuts, dude,
queen to behave like a basic be first of all,
just say. Cause you're you. We know what it means. Second of all,
when, when women refer to themselves as queen,
dude, it's it's, it's so cringy.
It's like when a guy says he's the King, like,
like, I'm sorry, LeBron is the. But he goes by King.
James is the worst
dude. There's no King of basketball.
It's so cringy to me. Like I feel it in my heart.
Like when, when people are like, Oh, that's a queen.
Look at.
The way she ran her own clothing line. Queen,
no Queens are running a clothing line. You know what a Queens doing?
Sitting around,
by the way, here's the other thing. You don't want to be a King.
You don't want to be a King. You're a guy. You don't don't call yourself a King.
Oh God. Like when a guy's in, we got it.
We've got a booth in Tao Kings. Only like, dude,
here's one thing that is for sure about a King.
If you're a King, you so bad.
Think about Kings. Think about how,
think about who actual Kings,
that rule lands you so
bad. You're lazy. You're in your throne or you're in your bed.
You're eating grapes. You know,
nowadays you're watching on Netflix or Hulu or Amazon prime.
And you're just sitting with your legs. When, when Kings lay down, dude,
their legs are so far apart because it's so disrespectful.
A King never lays down with his knees together.
He's always got his legs open and his balls out.
Like it's a to be eaten. That's a cane.
That's some kitchen and they're eating off of their belly. Dude.
You think Kings? good. Nope.
And I guarantee if you're calling yourself a King in modern day society here in
America or Ohio or Indiana or whatever the.
Cause you got a table at a club, you,
you're basically saying you bad. You splurt in a matter of seconds.
And that's it. And your BRACA cat, cat ain't even that hard dude. I'm no King.
You know why come on down a city where
we got all day long and I'll have sex with you for 11 minutes,
swear to God no longer. Because then you're trying to prove something.
You're no King dude. You splurt in mere seconds.
So if you're a queen,
I mean just don't call yourself anything that has to do with the Royal.
You know,
there are some people out there that call themselves princess too.
And those people, I like to call Persians because that's who does that? Hey,
I'm the pro Hey, what's up? I'm the Prince. Hey,
One time we laughed so hard in my, me and my friends were like,
we came out, we came out. We, I came up with the most Armenian,
the most Armenian thing you could possibly say,
This is the most Armenian thing you could possibly say. Okay?
Okay.
So if, if you, if you were in someone's house,
okay. And ed,
you touched their face by mistake, right?
Or even on purpose. This is the most Armenian thing you could say,
Hey dog. Okay. Hey dog. Don't touch my face.
I don't like that. I don't,
I don't come to your house and like put my fingers in your face and stuff like
that.
Wow. That's the most Armenian
you could possibly say is that someone touched your face in a
house and you said,
I don't come to your house and put my hands in your face and all that.
You don't see me coming to your house and putting my hands in your face and all
that. Oh my God. You know why? Cause they always find some
to be disrespectful about that. So not disrespectful.
Hey bro. Did you ask, did you ask,
You know why?
Because Armenians love to be disrespected.
Even though they pretend they're like, Hey, it's about respect,
but they love to get disrespected. That's why they're always being like, Hey,
Hey, Hey, don't lower. The volume dog. We're all here.
Don't lower the volume on, on, on during the commercial. We're all here.
What if we wanted to buy what's on the TV, bro? That's not cool,
bro. I mean how exhausting it is.
Oh, uh, with wearing the glasses with the that are,
that are so dark sunglasses that are so dark up top,
but then fade lighter as they get lower
sitting like this dude
Sitting like this, bro. Oh man. So funny.
They dude. No, no Armenian.
There's no Mo if you are an Armenian and you like any movie more than star
Scarface, you're not Armenian straight up.
They want everything to be like scarf.
They want life to be like Scarface so much. It's unreal.
Like Persian, Armenian lives.
They want it to be like Scarface so bad and it's so not. And it's,
and they try so hard. And so funny, dude, for sake, I have a friend,
one of my best friends, Persian. And he's just like, you know,
bro, it is,
it is like that.
It is like Scarface first. Oh man.
Life is like a first you get the money. Then you get power. Dan,
Dan only Dan comes respect and they work at a,
like a kiosk in the mall. You know? You're like really like, you're like Dan,
you can get after you get respect, then, then you can get,
uh, the, uh, the family plan with the mobile.
You can get a family plan if you have that. Oh.
Dude.
Like say hello to my little friend Nima. He's the manager. He will help you.
Oh dude. Ah.
I want to chill with all the Armenians and just chill one
day. God, they love. Oh, it's so funny.
I go to, um, coolest spilled coffee on my white shirt.
Karner for making fun of Armenians. Uh. I used to go to the coffee bean.
I talking about when I was talking to where I was, where I was,
where there was so many Persians and and I used to love, I want it to be,
I want it to hang with them so bad, but they didn't look like they would like,
man, I would do that, Joe. I would do. I did a joke.
Something like what I was talking about now on stage sometime at the ha
cafe, there were a bunch of Armenians in the crowd and dude, it was so fun, man.
We were laughing. I was making fun of him. I was saying that kind of.
And I was like, did you love the movie Scarface? And we were all laughing, dude.
that. awesome. See that's why it sucks.
It's like you could take what I said and be like, Oh I was bashing.
But it's like, that is so wack.
It's when you're making fun of someone with someone like that.
love, dude. It's love, man. Like, look,
we're all in this together.
It's awesome. If you make a joke,
then that's love, especially. That's what I do.
That's what I love in my life is to make jokes. If I'm doing that,
I love it. Anyway, this
girl thinks he's a queen who may also be sitting there looking pretty posing
with a cocktail in her hand,
wearing a nice dress who probably thinks doing these things means doing well at
life who will jump at the first opportunity to offer herself to any man who
shows her the slightest bit of attention or uh,
an or an ex note in exchange for an ego boost or for
himself at her expense.
As she clearly has no self worth respect or morals,
values has accomplished nothing in life and only her has her looks to offer,
which will fade very fast. I mean, Jesus Christ.
Then it really reveals your lack of vision,
intellect and failure to distinguish gold from stone. Jesus Christ. I mean,
this keeps going.
The sad truth is you are obviously also an unintelligent basic being
just like the basic be who is the only type of human.
You may be able to seek an invalid validation from your non-existent
confidence, self worth,
describing the need to be associated with validated by basic B as an
embarrassment is quite an understatement in my humble opinion. I mean,
nothing is humble about this opinion. You called yourself, good-looking a queen.
You said you sailed through three wall street firms
and went to the top notch school. And,
and you're like trashing guys and,
and you and you, and then you end it with,
in my humble opinion,
what is this world?
And the comments are slay icon or icons.
Another one that people throw around.
You're not an icon because you wrote a caption. You
can't dude. It's just also,
when you write a post like that,
no bashing involved here, like you only,
the only thing that is apparent is that you're so insecure.
Nobody like
how about when people are like, you know,
I'm, I'm intelligent. You don't like, why are you Kanye West dude,
nobody let other people say those things. It's about you.
You say that the only thing I think is like, Oh wow, everyone always says this.
Cause stro
so weird putting people back years too sad though. Honestly,
really, really sad. Like,
you know, I don't mean to be punching down, but kind of sad. Like,
I mean,
I'm obviously not going to say her name so you don't trash because I don't want
that. But my whole point is these captions.
They got to go. You're the first to go. They got to go. These captions,
just dinner at dinner you're here.
Let me shorten your caption for you had some drinks.
That's all that happened here. That's all that happened. Kay queen,
all that happened is you had dinner.
You're acting like you're on top of a mountain and it took you six weeks to get
up there. Nothing happened. You know what happened?
He put on an outfit,
these a long captions, they got to go, some comedians, do it,
talk about your comedy. You know, when you're on,
my comedy is shaped and evolved and this and that all really
let other people say that about you. You and other people say it about you.
I don't want to hear it. And if you're saying that about yourself, other people,
don't say, what about you? By the way, straight up, stop,
stop romanticizing your own life.
If you romanticize your own life,
the only person you're bringing down is yeah. Oh,
this is a cult dude. These are the things we learn at the log cabin.
And I've got a red laser pointer. And I point to all sorts of Instagram posts.
I say, no, no, no. This is a no. And what did she do here?
And what did this guy do here? Somebody raises her hand. Yes. Linda.
He said he was a King. Correct. And what is he doing?
He's just sitting in front of a bottle of crystal. Correct? And there you go,
Linda, you deserve some who wants to be sucking and Linda and Linda goes, Ooh,
I would like him. And somebody goes, I'll do it. Oh great. This is it.
The heater hedonistic lifestyle. Congratulations.
Congratulations, Linda, you get your and Craig, will you please go eat her?
I'll be happy to cool. There's some yoga mats out and the,
in the tall grass go do it outside.
Take it to the limit. And then, and then Armenians go like this. Oh,
did you know where that song's from? That's what I'm Scarface.
It's so funny because.